uh boston specifically is that like
their top five most valuable teams out
of any sport okay
part owner but i don't they didn't say
how much uh
how much you just own some shares yeah
so it's probably like minority owner
but you know like uh [ __ ] what's
named uh
bill maher for uh that you know he does
the yeah he owns the mats
he owns ownership in the map
damn so ownership just means like
because there's a jc you gotta have big
boy money you gotta have big jason
because if you have ownership you're
talking a billion hitting hundreds and
hundreds of millions oh bill maher's got
that
i got that big one big boy money i
didn't
one of my friends i met from uh usc his
dad owns a part of the warriors
stupid room like what does that what do
you do when you're a owner do you just
own a share do you have like any say in
what happened
no you have no say okay so it's kind of
like just holding us having this
thing about how much it's so valuable
because oh the value there's only
a few people in the world can own teams
and then the value of like the golden
state wars is through the [ __ ] roof
so i'm sure he could sell shares at any
moment [ __ ] banks
would you do that if you could i wish
dude yeah it's so hard
if you had all the money in the world
what team would you buy
that's a great question right for your
bills huh it would not but
[Laughter]
well the most valuable teams are like
the cowboys the lakers
the yankees yeah red sox is up there
what about soccer team yeah soccer i
think manchester united is number one
yeah oh my god
i'm trying to make money man oh no man
manchester's the big one man city's the
smaller like as far as like money wise
liverpool's big liverpool arsenal
arsenal's big
those premier leagues make yeah
damn for real what about the uh i'd
rather i'd rather own
a partnership in the ufc because i know
that sport
oh okay i know how to market and stuff
get help yeah that means baseball i'm
like i don't know
i'm pretty sure lebron let his handlers
just deal with that he don't know
anything about baseball
oh you're such a good investment though
because boston red sox dude
do you hear so his investors are like
pretty much handling
like a lot of that work yeah he doesn't
have to like do much he just
puts his money games on it but they're
like okay there's an opportunity for you
to buy into the boston red sox this is
how much it's gonna be there's only a
couple of
sockets like barcelona is that is that a
big one they're huge
so there's yeah go to top five most
valuable franchises in
sports sports it's yeah i'll before you
even show it it's
yankees man they're not in no particular
order but i think manchester
is number one yankees lakers
dallas cowboys and another premier
league team what do we got
oh i thought nick's up there dallas
yankees i said
lakers warriors real madrid patriots
barcelona
those are the top dallas cowboys number
one at 5.5
billion jared it's weird didn't it weird
because they're americans
who was number one yeah exactly but they
haven't won nothing
and they stay on what is it and how
about the knicks
i said awful but the next but they're
all so big yeah yeah but the knicks is
always but they're good this year but
they always been
in that room of the best sports team
but think how many people have money in
the world and it's so hard to get
ownership in the team
you don't see a lot of guys as like
having shares in like what you said
those premier leagues like barcelona
or arsenal you don't know who owns some
[ __ ]
yeah real madrid barcelona look at that
out of the 10
uh what do we got manchester united one
two three
three are uh basketball new york giants
most the most is basketball dude
uh you got one two three well it's kind
of you know
leaving because the coyote had three and
then you got yeah it's really basketball
football premier league so why
i mean no baseball i don't know i guess
just the yankees at five billion number
two
so wait the golden state warriors did
that not pop until like they became that
yeah that popularity so that's what and
then you add in the stadium which adds
value just have that new arena so that
helps
like all these things all those tech
guys broncos three bill i'm getting with
the broncos
you again with the broncos [ __ ] yes now
how many now how many people are
in like not many not many like usually
there's one like pat bowling
uh-huh the bowling family owns the
broncos the cronkies
and the rams and the crafts on the jerry
jones with the cowboys yeah it's usually
one guy
who's jay-z is it jake oh you're talking
about brooklyn he's part of brooklyn
yeah i think nelly's is too nelly is
part of uh
i know you're talking st louis not he's
something yeah but look at this
investment so the new york knicks
whoever bought that
paid 300 million in 1997. it's worth 4.6
billion now
the guy the guy uh he's in the band the
owner uh is it everything
everyone's hates him um the guy get he
got uh you know what i'm talking about
he's in the band they're back
she say nickelback is that it nah man
god they gonna kill me
uh just type in new york knicks oh no uh
um
not the google dolls um foo foo fighter
no bigger than that
uh you know who he is bro white guy has
has like uh
pearl jam no huge no
philly bruce springsteen no no he's not
from philly look at it
owner of what the new york knicks
it's my life
[Applause]
everybody i don't want to live for
everybody hates bon jovi
i like you oh i hate james dolan
everybody
he's just a piece of [ __ ] i was a
football team
philadelphia oh ooh that's a bummer my
bad
yeah i don't see it oh he owns an arena
team yeah well are the arena teams still
popping out bro they're doing the
[ __ ] rattlers were the one
yep utah blades shot the utah blades i
played for them you did it yeah
oh dude i've been to those arena
football games i used to go to the rally
bruh they are so lit oh [ __ ] damn i like
them you've been a real football
though yeah i fell asleep
it was the cardinals versus the steelers
oh no that was against the falcons they
were
and we just had got our we just had got
our stadium oh wow yeah i fell asleep
were you drinking at the time
was i i was a drunk i'm drunk right now
since you did this yeah
i'm a joke right now
the lawyer
he had to go to court tomorrow he looked
at that fridge oh yeah
i was saying last night when they
brought the dessert i said you know how
denzel feels in flight
when he walks in the hotel room and that
refrigerator
when that dessert came i was like i feel
like denzel
look at that
[Laughter]
that lip that's so bad like oh man
what a reference honey chin that's it
hell yeah
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son